hey those uh strikes are still going on
huh it's so annoying I think you should
give the actors and writers what they
want maybe I mean they seem pretty
reasonable delay
was that is that a word what is that
they want stuff I'm gonna take stuff
from them say goodbye to your precious
nerd crap nerds so basically you need
the big actors to promote the movie
right that's why you're doing this I'll
show them something that's just gonna
lose money moving it to a worse release
date I'll show them or you could give
the actors a good deal I'll show them is
this your only strategy right now oh we
hired a new PR firm seems expensive so
expensive is it working
I'll show them